hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt heute gibt es ein ganz schnelles
video von mir und ein ganz leckeres
gericht
ich werde heute nämlich eine
vegetarische lasagne machen und zwar
mache ich heute eine radtour ila sagen
ja und es eignet sich natürlich auch für
die veganer unter euch weil ihr nämlich
den käse und auch eine andere zutat
einfach austauschen könnt und dieses
gericht eben aus einem vegetarischen
gericht in ein veganes gericht
verwandeln könnte ich werde euch jetzt
einfach ganz schnell die zutaten zeigen
und sei durch dann auch schon
zubereitung für die radtour ihlas an ihr
braucht ihr drei paprikaschoten
natürlich lasagne blätter 200 milliliter
gemüsebrühe eine zwiebel und entweder
zwei große tomaten oder so wie ich jetzt
fünf kleine ich habe jetzt die kleine
und genommen weil die aromatischer sind
eine halbe aubergine eine halbe zucchini
etwas kräuter ich habe zur ikano und
hier ein paar verdienst blätter salz und
pfeffer und ich benutze später zum toben
etwas blauschimmelkäse ihr könnt da aber
zum beispiel auch einfach etwas
mozzarella nehmen und ihr braucht
außerdem etwas walnussöl und etwas essig
und zwar nämlich 13 rotweinessig aber da
geht auch jeder andere essig
eine zwiebel habe ich jetzt schon
geschehen und erzählt halbieren und hier
mit meinem kleinen schneidegerät klein
hacken und zwar habe ich hier einmal den
großen aufsatz und den kleinen und für
die zwiebel werde ich den kleinen
aufsatz nehmen weil ich einfach kleine
würfel haben möchte falls ihr die
zwiebeln mit einem messer klein
schneidet dann schneidet sie etwa in 5
mm große stücke das war nussöl gebe ich
jetzt in meine pfanne falls er kein
walnussöl habt könnt ihr auch einfach
etwas olivenöl nehmen und zwar etwa drei
esslöffeln die zwiebeln kommen dann dazu
und werden etwas klassik gedünstet in
der zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal die
drei paprikaschoten klein schneiden und
diese werde ich jetzt in 1 cm große
stücke schneiden und bei der paprika
gibt es den trick dass man einfach den
strom mit dem daumen ein drückt so hat
man nämlich keinen verlust an
fruchtfleisch und dann kann man sie
einfach halbieren und eben das mittlere
rausnehmen und sobald die paprika auch
schön klein geschnitten ist kommt sie
mit zu den zwiebeln und darf mit
gedünstet werden
in dieser zeit könnt ihr schon mal die
auberginen und die zucchini hälften
vorbereiten
und zwar werden diese auch in 1 cm
stücke geschnitten und kommen danach mit
zum paprika gemüse und dürfen dort mit
dem paprika gemüse weiter dünsten
zum schluss werden noch die tomaten
halbiert da mache ich es immer so dass
ich dann den strunk auf der einen seite
lasse den kann ich dann mit einem messer
entfernen und die tomaten daneben auch
klein hacken
die kommen dann auch mit zudem gemüse
werden ganz kurz mit gedünstet und dann
dürft ihr das ganze schon mit dem essig
verfeinern und zwar nehme ich da vier
esslöffel und lösche das ganze dann mit
dem mit der gemüsebrühe ab zum schluss
noch mit salz und pfeffer würzen wobei
ich jetzt hier bei nur benutzt habe das
ganze soll insgesamt so etwa zwei bis
drei minuten köcheln
zum schluss werden noch die kräuter
klein gehackt und kommen auch mit dazu
meinrad tatuhey gemüse sieht es so aus
es dürfte jetzt drei bis vier minuten
etwas karen und hier habe ich jetzt
bereits meine form eingefettet ich habe
eine kleine auflaufform das reicht jetzt
ganz genau für vier personen
da habe ich einfach etwas butter
genommen und jetzt wird die lasagne hier
rein geschichte zuerst nehmen dir jetzt
die lasagne blätter ich muss da immer so
ein bisschen die ecken abbrechen
damit es hier schön rein passt und dann
kommt da jetzt eine kurzzüge geschichte
von diesem gemüse drauf mit der sauce
das gemüse dürfte natürlich auch
abschmecken noch mit etwas
cayennepfeffer oder etwas chili sowie
ihr das gerne möchte ich werde so
aufteilen dass ich drei gemüse schichten
habe
das ist meine letzte schicht und ihr
solltet auch mit dem gemüse abschließen
also ich hab jetzt jeweils 30 schichten
und strahl gemüse schichten und mit der
note schicht habe ich begonnen nur mit
gemüse schicht schließlich ab und jetzt
nehme ich diesen blauschimmelkäse und
brösel den einfach drüber
da müsst ihr aufpassen da ist nämlich
ziemlich salzig deswegen habe ich meine
ratatouille gemüse jetzt nicht mehr nach
gesalzen
aber wenn er zum beispiel mozzarella
neben stifter gern noch etwas salz mehl
dazugeben müsste eben einfach
abschmecken
ich bin wirklich total lecker ich hab
den jetzt heute auch das erste mal
probiert beim kaufen und das wirklich
total gut und passt auch perfekt dazu
die lasagne kommt jetzt bei 190 grad
ober und unterhitze für etwa 35 minuten
in den backofen und danach zeige ich
euch das endergebnis
und so sieht jetzt die fertige lasagne
aus und die werde ich jetzt in vier
teile schneiden weil wir heute zur 14
und so könnt ihr sie dann genießen ich
hoffe dass ich dieses rezept gefallen
hat ihr könnt wie immer nachlesen auf
www.welt.de
ich glaube dass das gericht dem ein oder
anderen sechs strecken wird weil es eben
wie gesagt auch vegetarisch ist und auch
für die veganer geeignet ist wenn man
eben die entsprechenden zutaten
austauscht und ich hoffe natürlich dass
sich auch das video gefallen hat ich
werde jetzt natürlich wieder mehrere so
kleine videos auch mal wieder machen
auch zum thema kochen weil ich finde
noch ganz viel trocken und süßes kommt
auch mal wieder zeit für ein kleines
koch gericht und ihr dürft ihr gerne
auch einen kommentar da lassen wie ihr
das video verhandelt und das rezept und
natürlich auch was ihr euch als nächstes
wünscht beispielsweise für den sonntag
da möchte ich natürlich wieder eine
torte oder etwas süßes machen da dürft
ihr gerne einen wunsch verlassen
aus welcher kategorie ich es wieder was
machen soll ob es wieder ein classic
sein soll oder etwas nachgemachtes wir
sind ja gerade mitten im umzug deswegen
war das hier jetzt auch schon das letzte
video aus meiner alten küche ich werde
sie etwas nur vermissen weil meine neue
küche natürlich etwas größer wird und
ich da einfach auch viel mehr freiraum
für meine kamera habt und da denke ich
auch ganz viele tolle videos drehen kann
ich wünsche euch eins noch einen ganz
schönen tag und freue mich aufs nächste
mal bis dann